alors voilà
nous les avons croisés sur le long
chemin de l'exil de la turquie jusqu'en
allemagne en train en bateau
souvent à pied des familles entières des
racines est confronté aux pires
difficultés au pire danger et noir des
clôtures de barbelés au péril de la mer
egée leur histoire leurs témoignages
avaient été mus avait touché trois mois
plus tard nous avons entrepris de les
retrouver
c'est à la fin du mois d'août que nous
avions rencontré amjad al mounir à la
frontière entre la serbie et la hongrie
où une immense clôture venait d'être
installée au milieu de la foule marchant
sur la voie ferrée il n'avait pas pu
s'empêcher de pleurer je suis triste
parce que mon pays a été détruit
j'aurais préféré rester là bas et ne pas
voir toute la population fuir ainsi
amjad est maintenant installée dans la
région de darmstadt en allemagne pays
qui l'a atteint à présent perry de près
de moi et si la poussière a depuis eu le
temps de retomber
il n'oubliera jamais l'émotion ressentie
à son arrivée dans le pays
quand je suis descendue du train il y
avait beaucoup de gens pour nous
accueillir 10 à +17 5 un très beau
souvenir
je ne l'oublierai jamais oumar pouye
amjad vit maintenant dans un foyer
d'accueil pour réfugiés dans une petite
chambre qu'il partage avec son frère il
attend depuis impatiemment sa rencontre
avec les fonctionnaires du ministère de
l'immigration
s'ils trouvent le temps long s'il
s'ennuie jamais il l'a remise en
question cette décision de quitter son
pays
si j'étais resté j'aurais été enrôlé de
force dans l'armée heroes moremi des
armes dans les mains je ne voulais pas
devoir tirer sur mon père avait et dont
on chute maillon comporte deux heures
par semaine
amjad et son frère suivre mettant des
cours d'allemand et je fasse des cours
gratuits donnés par un groupe de
bénévoles comme je veux démarrer une
nouvelle vie en allemagne il est très
important d'apprendre la langue gisèle
qu'ici la clean your life in germany
entreprendre une nouvelle vie résolument
tourné vers l'avenir mais sans jamais
oublier le passé récent qui fait
désormais partie de l'ue taf séné lattes
j'en ai vu beaucoup en moi quelqu'un
accepte et je peux accepter beaucoup de
choses est ce que je ne supporte pas ses
devoirs des enfants dans les bateaux
c'est un pur - c'est inacceptable à
cannes signe et des enfants dans des
embarcations de fortune me ramènerait à
rezaï en a beaucoup voulu aussi c'est à
asos en turquie que nous avons fait sa
connaissance
en france quand c'est flou il
s'apprêtait alors à monter à bord d'un
bateau pneumatique à destination de la
grèce en compagnie de plusieurs dizaines
d'afghans c'était la première fois que
mohammed reza quitter son pays
la première fois que vous voyez la mer
et il ne cachait pas son appréhension
oui ça date
depuis que j'ai vu ce bateau coule et
j'ai peur la foule était jeune homme
s'était ensuite embarqué et avait filmé
sa traversée fait mouvementée
de matic surcharger un moteur en panne
tous avaient dérivé pendant plus de huit
heures avant d'être secourue mohammad
reza avait cru sa dernière heure venue
dap c'était un sentiment incroyable
juho domino
j'étais certain que j'allais mourir il
faut chaud on le passe niveau sur la
toile duo donne tout
touchant elle soutient
c'est en suède que nous l'avons retrouvé
dans une petite ville à 200 km au nord
de stockholm
des amis m'ont dit que la suède était un
bon endroit pour poursuivre des études
comme mon but est d'étudier
j'ai donc choisi la suède
le jour où nous lui avons rendu visite
coïncidait avec son premier jour d'école
en suède
ça sera un jour qu'il attendait depuis
longtemps
au programme des cours intensifs de
suédois pendant plusieurs semaines avant
de pouvoir intégrer le cursus régulier à
5 avec possible je veux commencer
l'école
et puis j'ai hâte d'aller à l'université
je vais tout faire pour devenir
ingénieur
depuis son arrivée au centre d'accueil
où il est logé me ramène reza ne cesse
d'impressionner par sa grande maturité
le jeune afghan ne laisse personne
indifférent
washington son histoire est très
touchante c'est un garçon très brillant
draka il a débuts dans l'élite
je pense qu'il ira loin
grosse erreur il faut dire que le chemin
jusqu'en suède n'a pas été de tout repos
dix pays traversés en 50 jours au cours
desquels il a à plusieurs reprises frôlé
la mort dans les montagnes en iran en
bateau sur la mer egée ou en autocar sur
les routes de serbie
on a eu un accident en serbie en allant
vers la croatie
trois personnes sont mortes et un homme
a perdu une jambe
moi j'ai été blessé au visage sans
surprise mohamed reza n'est plus tout à
fait le même que lorsqu'il est parti lui
qui n'avait jamais voyagé seul a
beaucoup changé beaucoup appris trois
membres et j'étais un fils à maman ne
faisait jamais rien de dangereux
mais depuis ce voyage depuis que je suis
beaucoup plus brasles in data bref j'ai
plus d'expérience et de confiance en moi
mais le courage et la confiance ne sont
pas un rempart contre le mal du pays et
la mélancolie
en quittant son pays mohamed reza a
laissée derrière sa famille son petit
frère nouveau-né et sa petite soeur de 6
ans à laquelle il est très attaché
il sait aujourd'hui qu'ils ne les
reverra sans doute pas avant trois ans
enfin m6
je m'ennuie beaucoup chaque fois que je
regarde les photos de mes frères et
soeurs à toi je me mets à pleurer
lorsque nous l'avions rencontré en grèce
après sa traversée
le jeune homme avait tenu à lancer un
message à l'intention des candidats au
départ
à oignies
nobody quand les chaînes que personne ne
devrait tenter ce voyage est ce risqué
la main sans avocat
trois mois plus tard même s'il est
arrivé à bon port le jeune afghan tire
les mêmes conclusions
et pour écrire une gaine à cette
tendance risque de tv quality and
feelings affronter et d'argent